so what i mean is that right now the  situation is completely different so do  not expect anything very strong on the  upside as long as we are in this  situation that's what i'm saying for  quite some time i know it's frustrating  i know that we expect more from amc but  amc cannot go against the market by  itself all right so what i mean is that  right now the situation is completely  different so do not expect anything very  strong on the upside as long as we are  in this situation that's what i'm saying  for  quite some time i know it's frustrating  i know that we expect more from amc but  amc cannot go against the market by  itself all right so what i mean is that  right now the situation is completely  different so do not expect anything very  strong on the upside as long as we are  in this situation that's what i'm saying  for  quite some time i know it's frustrating  i know that we expect more from amc but  amc cannot go against the market by